thanks to surf shark for sponsoring this
video find out more later on hey 42 here
do these numbers mean anything to you
if so congratulations
you're a millionaire
the internet's full of people offering
to make you rich but however much that
single mother made in just three months
online or whatever that nigerian prince
is offering to you as soon as you wire
him your investment i guarantee it won't
be a patch on what this simple set of
numbers could net you because cracking
this code is estimated to be worth
a cool 93 million dollars
the numbers are one of three coded
messages that make up what are known as
the beel ciphers which once cracked
contain detailed instructions as to the
exact whereabouts of and i do know how
this sounds
actual buried treasure
but
i'm getting ahead of myself
the story of the beale cipher starts in
the america of 1817 a young nation where
a person could find their fortune by
well finding it
all you had to do was gather a band of
like-minded adventurers pick a direction
usually west and head out in search of
that most precious of earthbound booty
gold
now if you love travelling then you'll
love the fastest and easiest vpn surf
shark did you know so shark also helps
you to avoid price discrimination based
on your location so you can actually
save money on plane tickets and car
rentals whilst traveling sur shark runs
on any device anywhere and it's packed
full of features such as
industry-leading uncrackable encryption
ip and dns leak protection an internet
kill switch if your vpn drops out and 24
7 customer support i personally use
surfshark to watch netflix content from
other countries such as the us that's
usually blocked here in the uk it's
really easy all i do is switch over my
location settings and there i have it
access to all my favorite programs
surfshark maintains a strict no logs
policy and their network of 3200 servers
in over 65 countries runs 100 on ram so
they couldn't log your data even if they
wanted to by using the code 42 you will
benefit from an 83 discount plus free
extra months for free all you have to do
is click the special link in the
description below so don't miss out
one such detectorist was a man by the
name of thomas j beale who set out from
virginia in 1817 with a group of 30
hunters and opportunists when they
reached the outskirts of santa fe now in
modern day new mexico but at the time
spanish territory they struck gold
and silver
i know they struck gold and a little bit
of silver just doesn't quite have the
same ring to it does it
anyway after 18 months of mining beale
and his crew had amassed a huge
stockpile of precious metals
all of which were transported back
across the country to virginia and
hidden in a secret location by beal
himself
but this hiding place which is rumored
to be somewhere within four miles of a
small town called montvale
was so well concealed that beale and his
companions began to worry that it might
never be found should something untoward
happen to them
to ensure their relatives would profit
even if the adventurers all perished
beale wrote free encrypted messages
one detailing the location of the
treasure
another its contents
and the third the names and addresses of
the crew and their closest relatives
beal then placed these precious clues in
an iron lockbox
which he entrusted to the care of
virginia ringkeeper robert morris
morris was given strict instructions
only to open the box if in 10 years
neither beal nor any of his crew had
returned to claim it
now i've known a fair few innkeepers in
my time and every single one of them
would have had that lotbox open before
beale had even left the building but it
seems robert morris was a man of strict
morals perhaps a little too strict even
because for some reason he left the
lockbox untouched for 23 years before
opening it
whether he was forgetful
pathologically incurious or just really
needed it to stand on to reach that one
high shelf
i guess we'll never know
what we do know is that being an
innkeeper with understandably limited
cryptography skills morris himself had
no luck decoding the riddles despite
spending the final two decades of his
life trying
beale had been supposed to mail morris
the key to the ciphers but he never did
and by the 1860s morris was beginning to
realize he'd missed his chance to find
the fortune instead of letting the
secret of deciphers die with him he
passed them on to a brainy friend of his
the identity of this arch puzzler has
been lost to the sons of time
but whoever he was
before long he'd made a breakthrough a
big one
he solved the second cipher
it turned out to be a straightforward
substitution cipher that used the us
declaration of independence as its key
when each number in the cipher was
replaced with the first letter of the
corresponding word in the famous 1776
pronouncement
the true meaning of the text revealed
itself the secret message contained
information about the amount of hidden
treasure
about how it was hidden
and even a few intriguing teases about
the other ciphers
but
not unfortunately that's all-important
location
it was certainly progress but
frustrating progress especially since
the two remaining ciphers remained
impenetrable but it seems robert
morris's mystery friend was good at more
than just cryptography because rather
than bang his head up against a wall for
a few decades as morris had he found a
new way to profit from the cyphers
he sold them now you might be picturing
some kind of grand auction with rich
types offering crazy money for the codes
but
morris's friends didn't sell the ciphers
to the highest bidder
he sold them to everyone
in 1885 he published a pamphlet called
the beel papers that contained
everything he knew about both the
treasure and the ciphers
selling it for 50 cents about 15 in
today's money the document was an
immediate success and copies of the bill
papers flew off the shelves in stores
all across virginia it was a genius move
really we humans are hardwired to want
to solve mysteries
that's why we have science and space
exploration and wordle we also love the
idea that we're special
fated somehow to score big where others
have failed
but perhaps most importantly of all
people just really want to get rich
and they want to do it quick
unsolved bl ciphers were essentially
worthless
but the elusive dream they represented
well
that was something people would pay for
nobody knows exactly how many would-be
adventurers have spent serious time
searching for the treasure
but it's most certainly hundreds
and very probably many thousands
some people hired mediums and
spiritualists in an attempt to divine
the location of the loot others tried
their luck with dowsing rods or by
consulting their inner eyes
in more recent years well-financed
treasure hunters have descended on
montvale with bulldozers and explosives
people have dug up graves trespassed on
private property
and made a load of giant holes in the
ground
and of course untold numbers of
man-hours have been spent trying to
solve the ciphers themselves
assuming the unsolved codes are likely
substitution ciphers too
all manner of different source texts
have been tested including but not
limited to the louisiana purchase most
of shakespeare's plays the magna carta
the u.s constitution the lord's prayer
the book of psalms
and the page turner that is the molasses
act of 1733. despite all this effort the
solutions to the first and third ciphers
has never been revealed
until now just kidding sorry
as of today more than 130 years since
the publication of the bill papers
the ciphers remain as
indecipherable
as ever and the treasure is still out
there somewhere
unclaimed
but before you grab yourself a copy of
the virginia gazette 1821 edition and
settle in for a night of word counting
i should probably point out that there's
reason to believe this story of buried
treasure
may be a little too good to be true for
starters it's very hard to find any
evidence that beal and his merry band of
explorers actually existed in the first
place
which is odd given the size of the parsy
and the fact that where they were headed
the western frontier was highly likely
to get them arrested for trespassing on
foreign soil
you'd have thought a journey like that
would have left a footprint
but from what historians have been able
to tell
well
it didn't
then there's the linguistic analysis of
the surviving documents experts have
compared the writing in several letters
purportedly written by beale to that
found in the bill papers which were of
course written decades after his death
and found remarkable similarities
both authors made near identical
grammatical errors and wrote in a very
similar style
suggesting they may in fact have been
one and the same person
beal's letters also contain several
words including stampede and improvise
that don't seem to have even been used
in the 1820s
even more evidence that this pamphlet
published more than 60 years after the
events it supposedly described
is nothing more than a fiction designed
to sell copies
okay
so the bl ciphers were just one big hoax
designed to sell a few expensive
pamphlets
well maybe
but also maybe not
the trouble is the evidence that
suggests to beale papers were a hoax
isn't exactly cast iron sure the
defaults on record of beale and his
cruise expedition would have survived
but hey this did all happen 200 years
ago
and whilst a linguistic analysis is
certainly interesting it also doesn't
really prove anything
nobody knows exactly which words were in
use in the 1820s we can map the
introduction of new ones by seeing when
they crop up in historical texts
but that's only ever going to give us a
rough approximation of true timelines
and for every piece of evidence casting
doubt on the veracity of the bill papers
there's a tantalizing hint that the
whole story might just be real
whilst no record of the expedition
itself has survived a certain thomas
beal was listed amongst the customers of
the saint louis postmaster in 1820
saint louis is located in missouri which
would almost certainly have been on
beale's route from virginia to the
frontier
there's even a native american legend
dating to the 1820s that speaks of gold
being discovered in the west and buried
in the east
of course none of this is remotely cast
iron either
but so long as there's the tiniest
reason to believe the ciphers might hold
the key to unimaginable wealth
people will continue to try and solve
them and we aren't just talking about a
few deluded dreamers hoping for a
miracle here
plenty of perfectly sane people have
gone in search of the treasure over the
years including several genuine
cryptology heavyweights
in the 1930s william friedman leader of
the us army signal intelligence service
which would later become the nsa spent
his spare time trying to solve the
ciphers
you might recognize his name for my
video on the mysterious voynich
manuscript so it's fair to say friedman
had a bit of a habit to solve the
potentially unsolvable
at one point he believed himself close
enough to cracking the bill ciphers that
he got his lawyer to write up an
agreement in case he succeeded
he didn't
but friedman never quit instead he
included the ciphers in the signal
intelligence services training program
one sis cryptologist who helped crack
japan's purple cipher machine in world
war ii
decided the ciphers were probably phony
but friedman himself was a little more
jekyll and hyde on the subject
he once famously said that on mondays
wednesdays and fridays he thought the
whole thing was real and on tuesdays
first days and saturdays he thought it
was a hoax
i imagine he was a pretty hard man to
live with
in 1970 renowned computing pioneer dr
carl hammer ran a statistical analysis
on the two unsolved beal ciphers
and found signs that they contained an
intelligent pattern
he was so excited by this discovery that
he went on to found the beel cipher
association or bca an organization
dedicated to solving the mystery of the
bill papers
for almost three decades the bca counted
a very large number of seriously
brilliant cryptologists amongst its
number including several from the cia
but
as the decades rolled by without any
sort of meaningful breakthrough the bca
seemed to have decided they cba
after all not that interest in the
mystery has ever totally gone away but
even as similar high-profile ciphers
from years past like those left by the
zodiac killer have begun to be solved
the beal ciphers have proven themselves
to be unbreakable whether that's because
they're just a random bunch of numbers
dreamt up by some guy as a genius way to
make some fast cash
or because we simply haven't found the
right key yet
well
nobody knows for sure the smart money is
probably on hoax in this case but so
long as an element of doubt exists there
will always be that chance of a huge
stash of gold buried somewhere out there
right beneath our feet
thanks for watching